let's be honest there are plenty of Call
of Duty players who only by the games
for the multiplayer if you're one of
those players add you prefer to play on
PC Activision has a special treat for
you for 15 bucks you can grab a
multiplayer only version of black ops 3
on steam it's called the black ops 3
multiplayer starter pack and it gives
you access to the weapon paint shop
gunsmith arena Free Run theater and the
black market store obviously there's no
campaign included but you also won't be
able to play zombies mode or prestige
you'll be capped at level 55 if you
change your mind you can always purchase
the full game and you're fifteen dollars
will be deducted from the total for now
the starter pack is a great way to get a
taste of what black ops 3 has to offer
this version of the game is only
available until februari 29th and
Activision has not revealed any plans to
release it on consoles if they announce
more we'll hear about it so keep your
sights on gamespot
you